[Music]
the world's most trafficked mammal is
one you may have never even heard of
the pangolin
despite its lizard-like appearance the
pangolin
is indeed a mammal
some pangolins are as small as a house
cat
while others are as big as a
medium-sized dog
pangolins are covered in as many as 1
000 scales which protect them from
predators like big cats
when threatened a pangolin's natural
defense is to curl up into a ball
unfortunately there's one predator that
pangolins aren't able to protect
themselves against
humans
according to some estimates poachers
have hunted more than one million
pangolins in the past decade
poachers use trafficking routes that
span the globe frequently shifting
routes to evade law enforcement
all eight pangolin species found only in
tropical asia and sub-saharan africa are
now at risk of extinction
pangolins are killed for a variety of
uses from medicine to luxury goods with
the greatest demand in china and vietnam
pangolin scales often powdered or made
into a paste are prescribed in
traditional medicine for everything from
relieving arthritis to stimulating
lactation
[Music]
however these remedies have no
scientific basis
[Music]
in fact pangolin scales are made of
keratin
the same material found in fingernails
pangolin fetuses sometimes consumed in
soup are erroneously thought to enhance
a man's virility
but only the wealthy can afford to eat
pangolin which is consumed in parts of
asia to demonstrate social status
in 2016
cities the international treaty on
wildlife trade voted to ban all
commercial trade in pangolins
however these creatures continue to be
poached at an alarming rate even causing
a devastating crash in asian pangolin
populations
recently poachers have increasingly
turned to african species
the largest confiscation of pangolin
scales occurred in 2017
which according to one estimate came
from about 20 000 african pangolins
making prospects worse for pangolin
conservation pangolins face habitat loss
plus they reproduce slowly giving birth
to only one baby a year
but why should we care about an animal
most people have never heard of
pangolin dealers are often part of the
same worldwide criminal networks that
drive other animals such as elephants
and rhinos toward extinction
plus loss of pangolins could prove to be
an ecological and economic disaster for
local communities
pangolins eat termites that might
otherwise destroy crops and buildings
pangolins also suffer abuses in the
wildlife trade such as force-feeding and
injuries from snares
a few lucky pangolins survive being
trafficked
confiscated pangolins in vietnam for
example may be sent to a rescue center
and returned to the wild
there's a lot of work to be done to
ensure the survival of pangolins
countries must work to reduce demand and
enforce laws against poaching
otherwise these gentle creatures may
disappear before most people even know
they exist
for the latest news on pangolin
conservation and other wildlife issues
check out national geographic's wildlife
watch
[Music]
you